we'll talk about two things a great deal
and a great conversation right they're
usually they're often going to be the
same thing but at times they're going to
be different that's a you mentioned
Vladimir Putin there is some zoom level
at which you do want to say we're on the
same side you said the human level it's
possible to say kind of zoom out
and say that we're all in this together
not we Slavic people we Europeans we but
we human beings the same Planet same
planet right
several years ago and his name is
evidently been mud now
um but he was very nice to meet uh
lawyer here in a town named Tom Girardi
and no shortage of
bad reporting on him now I have
absolutely no idea if any of it's true I
do know that in my interaction with him
he was always a gentleman to me and was
very generous
um when he'd get into conversations with
people he'd always say like you know
let's look at 10 years from now
where we could both be in a phenomenal
place together
now let's work our way back from there
that's a good line yeah and then you
know I saw him do it in simulations he I
was teaching the USC
and we were to function together
and a Gentleman uh at that time told me
that that who he was and it was really
influential so I walked up to the guy
cold and I said hey you know I'm gonna
come in and talking to my class at USC
he didn't know me other than the fact
that we had mutual acquaintance and he
graciously consented to come in
and he said what do you want me to talk
about I said look dude just from your
success here it doesn't matter what you
talk about
you know either I'm going to agree or
I'm going to disagree or I'm going to
learn from it my students are going to
learn from it so students want to role
play with them you know they dispute and
let's do a negotiation every single time
he'd go to pick a point in the future
where we're both happy
10 years 20 years from now and let's
work our way back now hostage negotiator
same thing
I call into a bank
bad guy picks up on the picks up on the
phone
and I'm gonna say I want you to live
you know I want to see you survive this
you know whatever else goes with that
let's pick a point in the future that
we're both good with
and then we work our way back and people
make also
um we're talking before about emotion
what you care about
people make their decisions based on
their vision of the future
like without question yeah uh there's a
I think there's a Hindu temple in the
United States
being a has been or being assembled same
way that the Hindu temples were in India
A Thousand Years Ago by hand volunteers
by hand
these people are knocking themselves out
for a place in Paradise a vision of the
future what you will go through today if
the future
portends uh what you want you you'll go
through incredible things today so it's
a vision of the future
so you have to try to paint a a vision
of the future that the uh the person
you're negotiating with will like
just tough to do let's find out what
their vision of the future is and then
remove yourself as a threat sure you
know if we can collaborate together
at all if you think that I could do
anything at all to help you
to that point and you know Integrity is
my currency
I'm not going to lie to you which gets
back before that I lied to you about
whether or not I'm on your side you know
right now not at the moment we're on
opposite size defense that's not going
to stop us from being together in the
future
inside you're going to say wow well you
didn't lie to me about today maybe you
won't lie to me about tomorrow
so going back to world leaders for
example whether it's uh Vladimir
zielinsky or Vladimir Putin you don't
think it closes off their mind to show
that
you have a different opinion
depend upon when you showed it is that
is are you arguing from the beginning or
are you displaying understanding from
the beginning I don't I don't think it
stops you from being adversarial that
was the thing about um
uh manukins
uh the chapter in his book The tense
tension between empathy and
assertiveness
I remember reading that reading that uh
name of the chapter thinking like hey
you know
in my business there is no tension and
then I got into it and I read I thought
this is a red herring
he's drawing people in because his
entire chapter is that empathy puts you
in a position to assert
and that there is no tension it's a
sequencing issue
and that's why again I think it's it was
written for lawyers yeah sequencing
issue so timing is everything so you
emphasize the importance of in terms of
sequencing and priority uh of listening
of truly listening to the other person
I'm sorry what'd you say that was a bad
joke
your timing is just perfect how do you
how do you listen
how do you truly listen to another human
being how do you notice them how do you
really hear them
I always hated the term active listening
if anything it's proactive
and as soon as you start to trying to
anticipate where somebody's going you're
dialed in more
um because along the way
either you're congratulating yourself
for being right
or when suddenly they say something that
surprises you you really notice it like
that's not what I expected
you dialed in you're listening so it's
it's
proactive and then
one of the reasons
you know we named the book tactical
empathy
um name the name the book never split
the difference but we're talking about
tactical empathy
uh calibrated emotional intelligence
what's calibrated by first it was
experiences hostage negotiators but and
we've come to find out that our
experience is hostage negotiators
is backed up by Neuroscience another
reason why I listened to Andrew
huberman's podcast all the time heavy
heavy heavy heavy on the neuroscience
and so then emotional intelligence
calibrated by what we know about
Neuroscience what do we know about
neuroscience and I'll talk about it from
a Layman's perspective and and even say
wheeze an arrogant thing you know human
beings I I didn't do the research I'm
scooping up as much of it as I can as a
Layman
the brain's largely negative
I think there's ample evidence people
would argue with you as to what the
wiring is and what does what
and the limbic system and all of that
but
the brain is basically 75 negative it's
an alignment I make that contention
number one number two
the best way to deactivate negativities
by calling it out
and I could say look I don't I don't
want you to be offended by what I'm
getting ready to say
that's a denial your guard is up you're
getting ready to get mad
if I say what I'm getting ready to say
it's probably going to offend you
now you relax a little bit
and you go all right what is it
and then I say it whatever it is and
you're going to be like oh that wasn't
that bad
because
we knew from hostage negotiation by
calling out the negativity deactivated
and then number of Neuroscience
experiments have been done right and
left by calling out negativity
deactivating the negativity
calling out ahead of time so like
acknowledging that this is
that this is go ahead of time that this
is going to hurt
the experiments that I've seen
um have been when the negativity was
inflicted and then having a person that
was being inflicted upon simply identify
it just identify yeah what do you feel
it I'm angry and the anger goes away
it's tough because I've had a few and
again we're dancing between things but
I've had a few conversations where anger
arose in the guests I spoke with
yeah and I'm not sure
identifying it
that that that's like leaning into it
and going into the depths
because that's going to the depths of
some emotional
psychological thing they're going
through that I'm not sure I want to
explore that Iceberg with a little ship
we got I
um it's a you have to decide do you want
to avoid it
or do you want to lean into it it's a
tough choice it's the elephant in a room
it is an outfit in the room it is an
outfit especially when I think that's
the big difference between conversations
and negotiations negotiation ultimately
is looking for closure and resolution I
think General conversations like this
is more exploring
there's not necessarily a goal
like if you were to put like if I had to
put a goal for this conversation there's
no real goal it's curiously exploring
ideas
so that'll gives you freedom to not call
out the elephant
for for time you could be like all right
let's go to the Next Room get a snack
and come back to the elephant right
all right so I I'd make a tiny
adjustment on the negotiation definition
sure because you said I think
um
seeking closure
you use two words enclosure was one of
them goals maybe another well yeah what
is what is negotiation well I would say
seeking collaboration
and because closure kind of puts a
little bit of a finality to it a real
problem in any negotiations always
implementation
that's why we say yes is I say we yes
there's nothing without how
and and yes and it's at its very best
it's only a temporary aspiration it's
aspirational it's usually counterfeit
so if you're looking for it's a good
life yes it's usually counterfeit it's
aspirational without the how yeah it's
just a good line yeah thank you and
we're working on it I was practicing I
in front of the mirror 14 came in pretty
good
you
should write a book or something right
yeah
[Laughter]
uh your book is uh excellent by the way
thanks appreciate that what am I doing
here anyway this on Earth with you I
don't know
we're collaborating
why me though why why'd you why'd you
want to talk to me I've heard you speak
in a few places I was like this this is
a fascinating human
um I think on clubhouse and different
places and I I listen to some YouTube
stuff and this is
just you've meet people that are
interesting that's that's why I love
doing with this podcast is just
exploring the mind of an interesting
person
you notice people sometimes you
sometimes it's like a homeless person
that's outside of 7-Eleven I notice who
are you yeah yeah yeah it's fascinating
it doesn't like I don't look at the
resumes and the credentials and stuff
like that it's just being able to notice
a person